just an only broadcast interview since
announcing he's going to step down as an
MP at the next general election
[Music]
good evening with the cold weather
biting you'd think it would be feeling
particularly festive in the week before
Christmas but as people count the cost
of rise and inflation many are
struggling coming up on the show today
I'm joined by Stuart Rose a conservative
peer and the chairman of the Asda
supermarket chain but first there's no
denying that the conservative party have
some ground to make up before another
general election they've been trailing
in the polls for months it's been a year
of very public disagreements and an
ever-changing cabinet and we've even had
changing Prime Ministers well one man
who knows what it's like to be near the
very top of government is the former
Chancellor and health secretary Sajid
Javid he's now decided to step down as
an MP at the next election and I sat
down with him earlier in his first
interview since making that announcement
say to Joe thanks for joining us on
again the program today really
appreciate your time now you are only 53
years old you're at the peak of your
powers in politics that you've recently
announced that you're going to be
standing down at the next election it
was a shock to quite a lot of people
around Westminster it's the first
interview you've done since you told the
world you have decided to go why are you
walking away well these decisions are
never easy and there's no such thing as
perfect uh timing but what actually
happened is that the party has asked all
conservative MPS to say what their
intentions are and for all the right
reasons and I've given a straight answer
but it is something I'd been thinking
about a lot over the summer you know
when I left it after I left as health
secretary and uh and reflected on things
and the first thing I say Beth is I'm
you know I've been very lucky I've been
in Parliament now for what 12 years and
almost all of that time I've spent on
the front line in six different
departments I'm proud of what I I've
done and the opportunities that I've
been given it's been a privilege and
whether it was as Community secretary
helping after the grenfell tragedy as a
Home Secretary with the the Windrush
Scandal and keeping the country safe
Chancellor helping to deliver brexit and
obviously most recently with the
battling through the pandemic so I'm
proud of that but I think there Comes A
Time for everyone to move on and and
what I will also say is that you know it
feels like in the last decade it's
almost like politics has been on some
kind of fast forward you know one crisis
after another one international
challenge after another and uh and
that's the way it is and you know
politicians are across parties they're
trying their best in that but it does
take a personal toll on you as well as
me as an individual of course but also
my family and you know when I came into
politics my kids were all very young and
their schools and now they're young
adults most of them and uh yeah I don't
want to miss out you know too much and
so I just think it's time for a change
but also I'll stay engaged in the in the
issues and the campaigns that I really
believe I mean you as you've said it
there you've been chance you've been
home secretary you've been Health
secretary you ran for the leadership
twice it's part of your reason then that
you've got nowhere left to go in
politics that you've kind of come to the
end of the road no I I wouldn't I
wouldn't say that I I as I say I've been
privileged to have the roles that I've
had under you know three different Prime
Ministers and I'm proud of what I've
been able to do but as I say there's no
perfect time on this that I think for
all politicians at some point of course
their their Korean politics comes to an
end and I and I feel that I'm at a stage
where I still feel young enough to to to
to to to do other things but also to to
do that important thing of of spending
more time with your loved ones with your
family and what you the Prime Minister
you you you you're close friends you
work together in the treasury what did
he say when you told him did he try to
dissuade you Rishi I think Rishi
understood I mean Rishi understands and
uh is a great man and and he's also very
much a family man too and uh and I I
think it's actually great he's put
himself forward in this way and it is
doing what he can for the country but
you know at a personal human level of
course he understands did he did he
offer you a job in October was that is
that part of the reason that you don't
like being on the back benches no it's
not it's not part of the it's I I made
up my mind uh in the summer and uh I I
didn't say anything for a while yeah uh
because there was you know we were just
obviously coming back to Parliament
there was a lot of change going on in
Parliament we've been through they won
our second prime minister yeah since
then quite a lot of time but uh I felt
now towards the end of the year we're
about to obviously go into a new year I
just thought it was the time was right
given the party had asked every MP and I
just thought let's just be straight and
give an answer and such you say the odds
are stacked against the conservatives at
the moment
um it seems crazy that doesn't it in a
way uh this is the week where three
years ago
Boris Johnson won a majority of 80 seats
it was the biggest conservative majority
since the days of Margaret Thatcher how
did it go so wrong well there's
first of all I'd say that the the big
International crisis that we've seen
that has affected every country the
pandemic the the one of the the the
biggest challenges I think as country
has faced since the second world war and
and that was going to be tough for any
incumbent government it didn't help by
the way in dealing with the pandemic
that we saw the rules were broken in
Downing Street and and people didn't
like that and rightly they didn't like
that and that hurt Boris Johnson in
particular but it hurt the government at
the time you were one of the first to
resign from his you were the fast in
that run of people resigning to resign
you resigned and then Rishi sunat
resigned and then dozens of people
resigned after you and that was the week
that Boris Johnson himself was forced
out of down the street when he toyed a
return
or an attempt to get back to be prime
minister in October what did you think
of that
well look I I backed Rashi at that point
and that's what I wanted to see and look
I I don't know what what was he or his
team might be thinking at that time and
it's really you know it's he was a
conservative MP and he is considered MP
he has every right to stand for the
leadership but I think we came out with
the right result and it was testing
during that time but we've come out with
the right result and we have amongst all
conservative MPS we have the best
possible leader we could have right now
and I do want to ask you about Liz
trauss Rishi sunup was your Deputy the
treasury before you resigned as
Chancellor and you've just said that you
think he's the best leader and you think
he's a really smart guy and you've been
full of praising this interview for him
but you back to Liz trust in the summer
because you preferred her approach to
the economy even though Rishi warned it
was fantasy economics how did quickly
did you realize such that you'd made a
mistake I wanted to see tax cuts I think
a lot of people did I liked what Liz was
saying about you know focusing on on
growth uh but but clearly you know when
she got into office uh what she actually
did and how she did it was was very
different right I I think it was uh
obvious right from the start really that
uh that that she wasn't going to be up
to the job in what way well because even
look even if you look back now even
before let's say that you know the
biggest challenge was the economy yeah
and if you look back and even before
that mini budget
in the run-up to that mini budget you
know the the sort of fighting that was
going on behind the scenes with uh the
bank of England I think was just
completely wrong you've got to respect
an independent bank of England uh the
sidelining of the obr the the
independent the office of budget
responsibility I think that was
completely wrong and then also uh before
that budget firing the the permanent
Secretary of the Treasury was completely
wrong I mean this was a gentleman's a
Tom scholar that has been serving
government over three decades he was my
permanent secretary he's one of the best
civil servants we have in this country I
think just treating someone like that in
that way was unacceptable do you think
the mistakes of that mini budget could
cost the conservatives the election the
next election like it was a it was a
tough time uh but uh I don't think that
that period that six week period is
going to cost us the election also when
when Jeremy Hunt came in as as
Chancellor and took the Reigns there
that he and then she soon after him they
moved very quickly to stabilize the
market and let's get on to the NHS
because you've both been the controller
of the past strings and the guy that's
controlling huge budgets uh when you
were Health secretary between June 2021
and July 2022 now the government are
locked in a dispute with narcis overpay
nurse is striking for the first time in
their history 70 000 appointments will
be canceled today there there's in that
estimate now former cabinet Mr Jacob
Jake Berry said last night the
government offers too low and the
government's going to have to improve
its offer on pay he's right isn't he
well first letter as health secretary I
had the privilege thing firsthand our
health workers and you're doing their
jobs and obviously including our nurses
and and what I thought day after day
were fantastic people doing incredible
work working very very hard off
especially during of course the pandemic
when it comes to pay I I do understand
at the moment whether it's nurses it's
other workers and stuff about the
pressures they're feeling I mean who
isn't feeling pressure when inflation is
at such a level you know almost everyone
in this country is taking a real terms
pay cut in in one sense or another but
when it comes to the NHS you have to do
what's fair of course and you have to do
what's affordable and I do think it is
fair that uh the government
did what it did which is accept the
recommendations of an independent
pay-per-view body I think the idea of a
I think the the RCN the nurses Union is
asking for a 19 pay rise I just don't
think it is Affordable no and I I think
that that probably would be a kind of
widespread view that 19 is a huge amount
but do you accept that they're going to
have to go up a bit like just in
practice more nasty strikes in January
it's your worst nightmare as a health
secretary the prospects of more strikes
do you not think it's going to force the
government to just it doesn't have to be
a double-digit pay rise necessarily but
to give a bit more to us no I
I don't accept that because I think you
have an independent pay review system
for a reason it is genuinely I've seen
this firsthand in whether it was as
health secretary as Home Secretary when
it came to policing and it's an
independent system when you were Health
sector I went back and checked the
numbers you were tasked with dealing
with the backlog when you started it was
5.3 million I went and checked this
morning back in June 2021 it's now
7.2 million is the system breaking the
health system here in this country well
first why is it going up when I started
I also said that the NHS had estimated
that because of the pandemic that some
10 million people stayed away from the
NHS not all of them are going to come
back but the NHS has I think sensibly
estimated at least half of them do and
that is why I also said it's going to go
up the waiting list before it comes down
sadly I think it's going to still team
took up for a while before it comes down
so that's what's happening the the sort
of second part of your question but is
it is it sustainable um look I having
worked up close now with the with the
health service and you know I I don't
think the the model of the NHS as it was
set up some 70 years ago is is
sustainable for the future you know that
the world has changed and the NHS has
not moved on right with that and and
Beth even before the pandemic it was
heading in that direction and that you
know because of the changing demography
you know people living longer therefore
needing more health care and a social
care for that matter new medicines and
needing that as well of course everyone
rightly wants to get access to to new
medicines and treatments and also the
changing burden and disease you know we
have a lot more obese people today we
have a lot more problems with addictions
so the NHS needs a change with that and
then if that wasn't challenging enough
something the pandemic comes along and
makes it much much worse when you say
the model of the NHS is not sustainable
in its current form the NHS is funded
through General taxation that is that
what you're saying that the way we fund
it at the moment is not sustainable
because it's it's breaking is that what
you're saying you need to look at
different ways
Fund in the NHS I think we need to look
at a a number of things as a country and
we need to have an honest debate about
the future of the NHS because we all
want it to be there for us in the future
for ourselves for our children providing
us with with really good health care and
and I think you know we we count no one
should pretend that that is where it's
what it's what it's doing because at the
moment people seem to be queuing for
everything and uh and we can't pretend
it's gonna suddenly get there without
radical change now when it comes to the
funding model I you know I'm not gonna
make sort of you know point to that on
the hoof without looking at the detail
but I would I would say that a starting
point would be to look at the Universal
Health Care Systems in other large
European countries if you speak to any
German you might know or a French person
or an Italian you know they they have
good Health Care Systems which were also
challenged by the pandemic but they seem
to be all be doing better than we are at
the moment and also if I may add to that
I think other things that we need to
look at is folks a lot more prevention
you know the NHS was was set up in its
day for dealing with people when they
get ill it only spends something like
you know three or four percent of its
Budget on prevention why can't
politicians in this country have the
conversation that you can now have with
me because you are not at the front line
anymore about how to make the NHS why
can't we the moment a politician of any
party says something that is obviously
correct about the NHS and and the
challenge it faces that someone else
will just jump down their throat and uh
and and turn it into something else you
know turn into the big negative you know
there was a story recently uh for
example Beth about I think I read a
couple of weeks ago I think it was in
Scotland yeah
there were some leak someone called a
discussion they had about maybe some
co-payment now I don't know whether
that's exactly the right system or not
but I actually welcome having that kind
of discussion you know because we need
to have this honest debate as a country
why that won't survive because look if
you look at
the NHS now
the only way it is
dealing with this record demand this
levels of demand is by rationing by
queuing and people are queuing for the
operations they're queuing for their
Diagnostics they're queuing for
ambulances they're queuing for GPS I
don't think anyone thinks that's a
sensible way to go forward and there's
no there's no overnight fixed magic
solution to that so you have to find a
way to to to help more with the demand
side of things as in you know more work
on prevention but also in the let's call
it the supply of Health Care I've got a
last question for you go for it this I
would like an honest answer you've
actually been very honest in this
interview you're a cabinet minister
you're in six departments you juggled
lots of policy areas and lots of
challenges what was your biggest success
and what was your biggest failure
or biggest failure
I I I don't know
um
you have to have to come back for that
one I mean they're they're failures
yesterday I mean I did you know it's uh
we all have uh challenges and not
everything works out the way you've
planned it uh in terms of um success
I I probably go back to Omicron when
that happened was just over a year ago
and uh there's lots of advice I was
getting from you know another lockdown
to don't do anything and in the end we
obviously decided I decided to rely on
pharmaceutical defenses and that meant
trying to boost all adults or 20 million
adults Yeah by Christmas within six
weeks and lots of people said it
couldn't be done and and the NHS and
everyone that worked on it you know and
more than did that 20 million people
boosted and I think it stayed the
country from a lockdown when I said
failure what popped into your mind
something did I I need to think about it
okay but I'm not I'm not but don't get
me wrong I'm not saying that because I
think they haven't been failures uh I I
think in any in any successful uh Walk
of Life that you you you don't get
everything and also you learn from
failure right I mean nothing can go
right all the time I know that all too
well as you leave politics what's one
thing you regret leaving on the table as
unfinished business how about that for
final question
um I I think we've just talked about it
and that's the NHS because it's uh it's
something it's so big it's something we
all rely on and I would have in a way
like to have more time to to to look at
reform to have that honest debate but
it's something I'd like to stay involved
in and and continue to campaign for uh
to get those improvements whether I'm in
politics or not such Javed thank you so
much for your time appreciate it thank
you
such a Javid there with some real food
for thought about the NHS now if you
scan this QR code on screen right now
you can watch all of our interviews
online and all of the previous episodes
of the show
this week we were told inflation has
peaked but at more than 10 percent the
costs of most Goods remain dramatically
higher than they were food inflation is
even worse running at more than 16
percent well Stuart Rose is the chair of
one of the biggest Supermarket chains in
the country Asda he says people are now
changing how they're shopping
Stuart Rose thank you so much for coming
on the show this week now you are the
chair of a massive retailer you have
been a retailer for five decades in
various different businesses we know
that this is the most important period
of the year for retail Christmas how
much do you think
people are being affected at the moment
with belt tightening because of the cost
of living crisis not spending on
presence on the little extras that they
normally buy this time of the year
there's some Beth it's kind of you to
remind people how long I've been around
I have been around the block a bit Yeah
but
um I'm one of the few people around
still working who can remember the last
time we had serious inflation in the
serious financial crisis back in the mid
late 70s and this is a tough Christmas
people are really really seeing the
Australian we haven't had inflation like
this for 40 odd years it's something
that people are not used to dealing with
and it's having a real very real effect
on everybody across the piece sad that
at the moment in the first Christmas
that we've had no covid that the lights
are on people are wanting to get out and
about that we've actually got this this
difficulty and then on top of that we've
got all the difficulties with strikes
and have you noticed that people are
just not spending as much listen um we
do a survey at Asda of which I'm
chairman where we know that 20 of
households in the UK are running a 60
pound a month deficit 20 of all UK
households now some of those will be as
the customers and some will be other
customers but if you're living like that
it's very tough people are making tough
choices so what we'll see is that people
I think will want a good Christmas
they'll want to have a nice celebration
on the day they'll want to look out for
their children but they've been very
thoughtful about what they can afford
and what they can't afford so Stu you're
saying that according to your surveys
one in five households are running a
monthly deficit so they get to the end
of the month and they're in debt
that's quite frightening because that
builds up but Beth without interrupting
you it's shocking
what do you mean it's shocking well it's
shocking that we live in in a place like
that today that there are one-fifth of
our households who are struggling and
I've seen it myself in stores people
come into the counter to detail and
saying well actually I've now spent my
25 on my 30 pounds on my 40 pounds that
I've allocated for myself this week and
you know don't put any more through the
till and we're seeing that so people
will cut back they'll look after the
children they'll have fun with the
family but of course they know that in
January they've got all the bills to pay
and they've got all the extra costs
surrounding the utilities and whatever
else and inflation is yet to slow down
but we're in this for the Long Haul
aren't we this isn't going to be
a return to better living standards
within 12 months for example for lots of
families well I I sort of half agree
with you I just think there may be a
little opportunity here that we mustn't
Miss first of all you're quite right I
mean since the austerity of following
the global financial crisis people have
in real terms had less money to spend
we've now seen a situation where you
have got inflation running at whatever
it is 11 you've got private sector
settlements running about six percent
six point two percent and you've got
public sector settling at about two
percent so there's a mismatch there yeah
people are worse off now I believe that
you know we can get inflation under
control I believe it's an imperative
that we do so mathematically it will
anniversaries it will start coming down
if we can get through this very painful
hump and don't get me wrong it's painful
for everybody particularly the lower
paid and not be caught up in this wage
uh price spiral which might happen if
we're not careful then I think that
towards the back end of 23 we might just
see easier times we have to look at each
one of these people who are having
strikes each one of these unions who are
calling strikes them up we need to look
at every case on a case-by-case basis
I'm not going to go into detail of who I
think has got the better case and the
worst case but some people are you know
pushing it a little bit harder than
perhaps they should and some people do
deserve these Rises so it's not a
question of who deserves a rise it's a
question how much can we afford to give
people and when can we afford to do it
and if we all just take a little bit of
thoughtfulness or give a bit of
thoughtfulness about the implications if
we get it wrong then we might just end
up at the right place so I'm not asking
people to sacrifice I'm asking people to
be thoughtful so do you think the rail
workers are pushing it in the nurse's
aren't well I'm going to leave you to
draw your own conclusions but people you
know the Great British public I've
always said the other day that you
thought narcissists deserved a pay rise
because nurses definitely deserve a pay
rise but you know at the end of the day
the nurses are asking for a big
double-digit increase now you have to
ask yourself is that affordable the
answer is in the current state of the
National Health Service it probably
isn't as is currently the third largest
supermarket chain in the UK do ministers
meet with you to discuss the cost of
living difficulties people are facing
and about how government and business
together might be able to better help
people do you have those conversations
would you just do it off your own back
I'm non-executive chairman so I don't
have an executive capacity in the
business a sense but Management in ASDA
do have contacts of course we do uh with
politicians particularly on a local
basis I think it's fair to say and you
know the relationship between government
and business in the last two or three
years has been pretty Rocky it's been
pretty up and down uh it's good to see
uh under the new Premiership now that
we've got you know Beginnings now sort
of let's build some bridges it's the
same with what we're seeing in terms of
the labor party in terms of what they've
put out in terms of Who You Manifesto
and politics that's true why was it
pretty rocking up and down in the past
couple of years with business and
government well I don't have to remind
you what was it the previous prime
minister but three said I've lost count
of how many premises you're correct the
previous prime minister but three I'm
not going to repeat it on TV but that's
how we felt the expletive business
and you you thought Boris Johnson was
bad for business then well I don't think
if business was on his agenda to be
perfectly honest with you and at the end
of the day we have to remember we live
in a free market economy we live in a
capitalist Society we don't know any
better system than capitalism capitalism
is the creation of wealth we then have
to work out how to distribute that
wealth and we can have our arguments
about that but the short answer is if we
don't create wealth we can't create and
spend money on taxes or pay taxes create
infrastructure and build a better
Britain you you've obviously led many
businesses with with big workforces did
you think do you dislike Boris Johnson
you seem to dislike him or you don't
think he was a good leader well I have
to be verbally honest with you it's not
a question of like or dislike you know
you expect when you have a leader that
your leader to be a fit for purpose and
I perfectly don't I don't think that
Boris Johnson was fit for purpose
whatever he may claim that he got but
brexit does a huge majority he did get a
huge majority but we are paying the
price for some of the decisions that
were not made or were made by that
government now some will disagree with
me but it's interesting that I'm a
conservative peer and I say that okay
you're a conservative here we just said
you were clearly unhappy about the trust
Administration you didn't much like
Boris Johnson you asked the trust public
to resign did you ever or do you ever
think about giving labor a look
um well isn't that
by a very dear friend uh Lord miners who
was a labor peer died earlier this year
and he always used to tease me and say
look you're not a proper conservative
Steward I'm a conservative principle I
call myself a conservative with a small
C uh I believe in the free market
economy and I believe in conservatism I
won't deny that I haven't been slightly
disillusioned by what we have seen in
the last three or four years everybody
knows and you know I may not have had a
great job of it but I was you know
involved in the in the great debate
about brexit I absolutely accepted when
we lost that that we lost it but I don't
believe and this is where I've got a
real gripe that day one after that
decision was made that we've made the
best of what we could have done so here
we are six years later you know our
trade with the EU has gone down we
haven't done trade deals with anybody
else we're still arguing about can we
get one with the Indians or can't we
we've given up pretty well on can we get
one with the US of a so these are real
issues and in the meantime we've got a
an economy which is struggling I've seen
some interviews that you've done
subsequently about brexit you obviously
were a leading figure leading business
voice in the I was the only one there
was a very few people who were prepared
to count unfortunately up and put their
heads above the power but it was
difficult for retailers wasn't it
because customers were divided and you
you associate politically in that that
person I'm not sure I agree with you I
think that we are well that was the
argument retelling there was the
argument but it's not just retailers
business people it's just people it
doesn't matter what debate you've got
going on about what in you know here
we've got a debate going at the
motorbike immigration we've got a debate
going on about the Northern Ireland
protocol we've got a debate going on
about all sorts of things I think
business people because leadership is a
privilege with the privilege of
leadership comes the responsibility and
I think we have to take responsibility
for saying what we believe to be right
we can't just look around the corner and
say well I better not say that because
my upset part of my community you didn't
like Liz truss you didn't like it well
you didn't I've never met Liz trust well
you thought it doesn't okay I publicly
called on Liz trust resigned didn't
think she was fit for purpose I don't
think I was wrong you you you you said
yourself you didn't think Boris Johnson
was fit for purpose and you don't think
that the government have executed brexit
in a way that benefits the economy could
you vote for kirstama in 2024 I will
look very hard when I get well the good
news for those people who are worrying
about that I can't vote because I'm a
conservative appears don't vote but they
ask that question but I will look very
hard at what is on offer and what I
would say to people is
even as a conservative look what's on
the market stall a look what's on Market
stall be and make a choice but make a
choice an informed Choice make sure you
know the facts make sure you know what
you think could be delivered make sure
who's delivering it ask yourself the
question can these people actually not
only talk the talk but walk the walk and
then make your decision about what you
vote for let's see what happens and
you're sitting on the fence at the
moment you're not sure no I think that I
think that that we have I first of all
I've always been slightly wary about not
having a strong opposition we haven't
had strong opposition for a long time so
it's good to see some proper opposition
and that will always sharpen the pencil
of the incumbent government the
incumbent government for all the reasons
you know better than I do have spent
three or four years fighting each other
at the cost of the UK PLC I firmly
believe that we have actually in a world
that's moving very fast in a world
that's very dangerous in a world where
alliances have been formed all over the
place all the time we have sat there and
started banging each other on the nose
to what purpose
okay Stuart Rose thank you very much
we're going to see if you're going to be
crossing the floor of the House of Lords
now thank you so much for your time well
that's all for today's show and all for
this year we'll be back next year with
more interviews for you but we do have a
very special program running over the
festive period with some of my favorite
bits of the show thanks to all of our
guests this year and thanks most to all
of you for watching
[Music]